[Música]
hola bienvenidos a kobe 19 la semana en
américa soy santiago lópez gonzález este
es el espacio de france 24 en el que
hacemos un resumen de las noticias más
destacadas relacionadas con la pandemia
de kobe 10 si no había continuación los
temas que vamos a analizar en esta
edición
hubo anuncios muy importantes en eeuu a
lo largo de esta semana el presidente de
ese país joe biden anunció la donación
de 500 millones de dosis de vacunas para
que sean entregadas a través del
mecanismo kóvacs a países de bajos
ingresos esto mientras eeuu también se
perfila como el líder en la vacunación
de adolescentes mayores de 12 años
tenemos los detalles y con algunos de
nuestros corresponsales haremos un
recorrido por américa del sur para
conocer los detalles de la situación
actual por ejemplo chile pese a estar
liderando la vacunación a nivel regional
la región metropolitana de santiago va
nuevamente a un confinamiento estricto
este fin de semana y en bolivia también
por ejemplo la cifra de fallecidos
supera los 15.000 y allí están faltando
lo en los tanques de oxígeno en algunos
de los principales hospitales en las
grandes ciudades bolivianas mientras
tanto en paraguay allí recibieron un
lote de vacunas sputnik de que se espera
que con estas impulsen la inmunización y
también daremos un vistazo a uruguay en
donde comenzaron también a vacunar a los
adolescentes y también ya estarían
pensando en regresar a las clases
presencia
hablaremos también de haití un país que
no ha recibido el primer lote de vacunas
contra el jove 19 mientras tanto los
números de contagio están aumentando
también el de los fallecidos cifras que
podrían poner en aprietos a ese sistema
de salud de ese país debido a la gran
cantidad de pacientes que se están
presentando haití está haciendo frente a
un pico de contagio sin vacunas y con
una precaria infraestructura
hospitalaria vamos a ver cómo está el
panorama pues vamos a comenzar como les
estaba diciendo en eeuu allí más de la
mitad de los ciudadanos mayores de 12
años ya están completamente vacunados
según las autoridades sanitarias el
número de contagios diarios va en
descenso gracias a la campaña de
inoculación a nivel nacional de otra
parte la casa blanca anunció que va a
donar 500 millones de dosis de vacunas
para los países de menos ingresos veamos
en eeuu parece que el peor momento de la
crisis sanitaria ya pasó el país sigue
siendo el más golpeado por el cob y 19
en términos absolutos con alrededor de
600.000 fallecidos y más de 33 millones
de contagios sin embargo en la última
semana el promedio de nuevos casos
diarios está por debajo de 100.000 uno
de los más bajos desde que comenzó la
pandemia expertos y autoridades
sanitarias lo atribuyen a la agilidad en
el proceso de vacunación según
información de los centros para la
prevención y control de enfermedades del
50,1 por ciento de los mayores de 12
años ya está vacunada completamente y un
61,2 por ciento tiene al menos una dosis
los mayores de 12 años ya pueden ser
inoculados con la inyección de facer
bayón tec mientras que el laboratorio
estadounidense moderna solicitó a los
reguladores la autorización para uso de
emergencia de su vacuna en esta misma
población con más de la mitad de su
población vacunada la casa blanca
anunció que ahora donará 500 millones de
vacunas a 92 países de bajos ingresos la
mvp permítanme ser claro al igual que
con las 80
millones de dosis que anunciamos
anteriormente eeuu está proporcionando
500 millones de dosis sin condiciones
permítanme decirlo de nuevo no sin
condiciones nuestras donaciones de
vacunas no incluyen presión para obtener
favores o concesiones potenciales
estamos haciendo esto para salvar vidas
para poner fin a esta pandemia eso es
todo punto
kerry estas dosis que serán adquiridas a
la farmacéutica pfizer serían entregadas
desde agosto y durante los próximos dos
años para ser distribuidas a nivel
mundial a través del mecanismo copagos
y así cierra esta semana la vacunación
en algunos de los países de américa
latina' veamos las cifras el número de
personas que han recibido al menos una
dosis de alguna de las vacunas que están
disponibles en el mercado el consolidado
de américa del sur nos dice que ya 96
punto 92 millones de personas han
recibido al menos una dosis en américa
del sur
'brasil 52.43 millones de personas en
méxico llega ya a los 25 puntos 31
millones de personas con al menos una
dosis le sigue canadá
allí alcanzan el 24.01 millones de
personas y vamos a cerrar esta
información con costa rica que ya
alcanzan 1.22 millones de personas con
una dosis para el cierre de esta semana
y vamos a ir hasta chile donde ya lo
decíamos la vacunación sigue siendo el
ejemplo para la región latinoamericana
pero aún así hubo anuncios esta semana
anuncios que sorprendieron incluso hasta
los mismos chilenos vamos a conocer los
detalles con patricia luna desde
santiago la capital o la patricia pues
precisamente lo estábamos diciendo en
santiago y el área metropolitana el
gobierno anunció que deberán ir
nuevamente a un confinamiento una medida
que tomó por sorpresa a los capitalinos
que fue lo que sucedió
hola santi es como un jarro de agua fría
asentado para muchos la decisión del
gobierno de decretar una nueva
cuarentena total a partir de este sábado
en la región metropolitana en la que
viven 8 millones de los 19 millones de
chilenos esta será la tercera vez en
toda la pandemia que la región
metropolitana entra en el modo de
cuarentena total esto ante el alta
sostenía en el número de casos que se ha
visto en las últimas semanas chile
alcanza aproximadamente un millón y
medio de contagiados desde el inicio de
la pandemia y supera los 30 mil muertos
y vemos que el sistema hospitalario se
encuentra completamente colapsado
saturado en un 96 por ciento a nivel
país esta cifra asciende hasta el 98 99
por ciento en el caso de la región
metropolitana donde desde hace días ya
sabemos que no hay más de una treintena
de camas disponibles para toda la región
metropolitana este viernes veíamos como
algunos hospitales decidían cerrar sus
puertas y no admitir a más pacientes
mientras que los centros sanitarios
barriales comienzan a admitir a aquellas
personas que se encuentran en estados
menos graves
patricia chile está siguiendo los pasos
de uruguay y también planea empezar a
vacunar a los adolescentes
en esta semana anunciaron que una nueva
vacuna va a entrar en el mercado chileno
para reforzar ese plan de vacunación y
llegar a la meta que se ha propuesto el
gobierno que han dicho las autoridades
el instituto de salud pública aprobaba
el uso de emergencia de una quinta
vacuna en el país se trata de la vacuna
de janssen johnson johnson de una sola
dosis que se une a otra vacuna de una
sola dosis que ya existe en el país y ya
se administra la vacuna de cannes y no
junto a las vacunas de astrazéneca
oxford la vacuna de facer y la vacuna
china sinovac es la que se ha
administrado de forma mayoritaria en el
país en cuanto a noticias de vacunación
sabemos también que a partir de este 21
de junio se comenzará a vacunar a
aquellos adolescentes entre 12 y 17 años
se comenzará con la red de orfanatos
públicos del estado del servicio
nacional de menores y aquellos
adolescentes que tengan enfermedades de
base matrices hagamos un balance de la
situación general del país porque ya
hablábamos de lo que está sucediendo en
la región metropolitana pero qué pasa en
las otras ciudades grandes de chile en
las otras regiones cómo está avanzando
también la vacunación allí
la gran incógnita santiago es si va a
funcionar o no esta cuarentena teniendo
en cuenta que 42 de las 52 comunas de la
región metropolitana ya se encontraban
bajo cuarentena hasta ahora incluida la
zona en la que nos encontramos en las
que vemos un tráfico bastante fluido de
personas en estos momentos se restan
aglomeraciones en los comercios y
también en los supermercados la gente
cuando se decreta una cuarentena suela
como acudir en masa y se aglomera para
tratar de habituarse a administrarse de
cosas que piensa que luego no va a poder
conseguir es un efecto normal de las
cuarentenas pero esta cuarentena ha sido
criticada incluso por parte de uno de
los partidos que conforman la coalición
chile vamos la audi que ha afirmado ha
criticado duramente al gobierno al
señalar que las cuarentenas ya no sirven
para nada y que no tienen la efectividad
que tenían antes esto también entre
críticas de los sectores comerciales y
gastronómicos que se verán perjudicados
por este nuevo cierre total de las
persianas en un año que ha sido bastante
complicado para todos mientras la
vacunación sigue avanzando a un ritmo
más lento que al comienzo en el país
y a un 75% de la población objetiva de
15 millones de personas recibió una
primera dosis de la vacuna y un 58 5
recibió las dos dosis de la vacuna
mientras el llamado de las autoridades
sigue siendo a que la población más
joven que no ha acudido a vacunar
siguiendo el calendario cuando le
correspondía lo haga hay aproximadamente
900.000 personas que se encuentran
rezagadas las autoridades insisten que
las unidades de cuidados intensivos
aproximadamente más del 80% de las
personas que se encuentran ingresadas no
han completado su esquema de inoculación
mientras que en las unidades de cuidados
intensivos también se registran personas
menores de 50 años en un número tres
veces mayor a lo que veíamos en la
primera ola patricia pues más que claro
el panorama allí en chile muchas gracias
por este completo reporte desde la
ciudad de santiago y a mantenerse
entonces en casa por este nuevo
confinamiento nos vamos ahora hasta
bolivia este país superó los 15 mil
fallecidos por kobe 19 mientras que
también día a día está rompiendo su
propio récord de contagios en medio de
un nuevo rebrote ya son más de 400.000
las personas contagiadas
mientras que los vacunados ya superan
los 1.5 millones de personas en todo el
territorio boliviano veamos
y demoradas filas para vacunarse ya son
comunes en bolivia los habitantes de las
principales ciudades se aglomeran en las
puertas de los centros de salud en plena
escalada de contagios con la esperanza
de ser inoculados desde las 7 de la
mañana de hecho fila no había un poquito
de orden para hacer el distanciamiento
social o sea que como estaban muy
pegaditos la tercera ola de la pandemia
de kobe 19 que afecta al país desde
principios de mayo ha dejado jornadas
con más de 3000 contagios y un centenar
de muertes las más altas desde el inicio
de la crisis cifras oficiales dan cuenta
de más de 15.000 muertos acumulados
aunque hay quienes denuncian que el
recuento es mucho más alto
el estudio del excedente de muertos que
se tiene a través del registro en el
servicio de registro cívico que se llama
ceres y en bolivia tenemos un acumulado
entre muertos oficiales muertos por
excedentes cada mes de 33 mil 393 hasta
el mes de abril
esto significa que seguimos con un
excedente que va más allá del doble de
la cantidad de muertes oficiales las
camas de cuidados intensivos están cerca
de rebasar su capacidad en medio de una
lucha por conseguir oxígeno en ciudades
como cochabamba en donde ya escasea
este recurso vamos a profundizar en la
situación en bolivia en la paz esta
meriva acá con más información o la mary
pues ya lo estábamos viendo en el
informe es considerable el aumento de
los fallecidos allí en bolivia más de 15
mil personas ya han muerto que dicen las
autoridades sobre estos números que son
alarmantes para este país suramericano
hola qué tal santiago bolivia está
viviendo su peor momento no solamente en
el marco de la tercera ola sino de toda
la pandemia tal como acabamos de
informar más de 15.000 personas han
fallecido por kobe 19 en lo que va de la
crisis sanitaria pero además el
instituto de investigaciones forenses ha
informado que durante 2020 y 2021 ha
procedido al levantamiento de más de
7000 cadáveres de las calles y de las
casas todos ellos sospechosos de kobe 19
y todo indica que estos cuerpos no han
ingresado a los registros oficiales por
otro lado les comento que bolivia ha
batido todos sus récords los últimos
días por ejemplo ha llegado a registrar
115 muertos en una jornada y casi 4.000
casos positivos de kobe 19 en un día
estos datos para un país de 11 millones
de habitantes son preocupantes pero las
cifras de fallecidos son lamentables
hablemos de la situación general porque
los hospitales también están saturados
sobre todo hay un problema particular en
este país hay muchas dificultades para
garantizar el suministro de oxígeno y de
medicamentos que es lo que está
sucediendo
ese es otro drama en los casos de
cochabamba y santa cruz la gente está
sometida a verdaderos calvarios para
conseguir por ejemplo oxígeno para sus
familiares que están enfermos de kobe 19
la gente ha tenido que dormir varios
días y acampar en las puertas de los
establecimientos para conseguir tubos de
oxígeno y en muchos casos pagando
precios elevadísimos por otro lado los
bolivianos han terminados sometidos al
mercado negro de las redes sociales para
acceder a fármacos para unidades de
terapia intensiva a precios también
altos pues no se encontraban o no se
encuentran todavía en los centros
formales en cuanto a unidades de terapia
intensiva la situación es muy parecida
en cochabamba y santa cruz estas están
colapsadas y en el caso de la paz la
situación también empieza a ponerse
crítica desde los últimos días pues los
casos están aumentando aceleradamente
mediante esta coyuntura que dicen las
autoridades que plan han diseñado para
hacer frente a este pico de la pandemia
cobain 19 hay en bolivia y sobre todo
qué plan tienen para la reactivación
económica del país
el gobierno de luisa se ha apostado
básicamente por la reactivación
económica y por tanto es un gobierno que
se opone a las medidas restrictivas por
ejemplo a la circulación en todo caso
las regiones más afectadas por esta
tercera ola han decidido ir a
cuarentenas parciales durante los fines
de semana y también los feriados y en el
caso del gobierno central básicamente
está apostando al plan de vacunación
como una forma de prevención de los
contagios pero este plan tampoco ha
avanzado mucho pues alrededor del 6% de
los bolivianos tienen las dos dosis de
vacunas y cerca del 20% solamente ha
accedido a una dosis como podrás ver la
situación es preocupante en el país
preocupante situación en bolivia mery
muchas gracias por este completo reporte
desde la ciudad de la paz en bolivia y
vamos ahora hasta paraguay el proceso de
vacunación allí está avanzando
lentamente tanto así que semanas atrás
les estábamos reportando sobre algunas
manifestaciones ciudadanas que exigían
acciones para acelerar la inmunidad
pero paraguay solamente está recibiendo
lotes de vacunas a través del mecanismo
kóvacs no realizó compras de manera
directa con las compañías farmacéuticas
vamos a conocer entonces cómo está allí
la situación conectamos en asunción con
fernando boc ya él está allí en la
capital paraguaya para darnos más
información
fernando hagamos entonces primero un
panorama cómo está la situación general
allí en este país siguen aumentando los
casos rápidamente y también la
infraestructura hospitalaria está bajo
presión
la situación es sumamente crítica esta
semana en paraguay se ha atravesado la
barrera de los 10.000 muertos por
coronavirus esta cifra puede parecer
bastante pequeño en relación a países
como brasil donde ya hay más de 480 mil
fallecidos por esta enfermedad
sin embargo proporcionalmente es muy
alta paraguay hoy lidera el ranking de
países con mayor cantidad de nuevas
muertes por ccoo y 19 por millón de
habitantes las camas de terapia
intensiva están totalmente saturadas con
más de 600 pacientes ahora mismo y el
gobierno ya anunció que debido a la
falta de personal sanitario no se podrá
aumentar la capacidad hospitalaria para
dar un ejemplo en los últimos cinco años
paraguay ha mantenido un promedio de
entre 500 y 600 muertes semanales ahora
mismo paraguay está teniendo entre 1.100
y 1.200 muertes semanales incluidas la
de kobe 19 esto significa casi el doble
de la tasa de mortalidad en el país
fernando hablemos de la vacunación punto
importante además esta semana hubo
noticias
paraguay llegó un lote de vacunas de
sputnik desde moscú vía buenos aires y
con esto esperan darle un leve impulso a
ese lento proceso de vacunación en
paraguay que dicen allí
si el último cargamento de vacunas que
lleva a paraguay es un lote de 40 mil
dosis del sputnik de compradas de rusia
el gobierno no tiene la seguridad para
informar cuándo será el próximo cuando
llegará el próximo cargamento a casi
tres meses del inicio de la campaña de
vacunación en paraguay llegará un poco
más de 500.000 dosis de diferentes
vacunas contra el propio 19 muchas de
ellas donadas a pesar de que el gobierno
compró más de 8 millones de dosis a
través de distintos mecanismos la
campaña de vacunación se realiza en
medio de una escasez de vacunas por un
lado y por otro lado con un
descreimiento de la población gran parte
de la gente que tiene más de 60 años la
requerida para acceder a una dosis no
está acudiendo a los centros de
vacunación esto es objeto de críticas
para el gobierno debido a la falta de
campañas de concienciación sobre la
importancia de la vacuna contra el varón
a virus
fernando llama mucho la atención un
anuncio también hecho esta semana en
torno a la vacunación de las mujeres
embarazadas porque causó tanta
controversia este anuncio allí en
paraguay qué información hay al respecto
luego una larga espera para muchas
mujeres y sus familias finalmente arribó
al país un lote de 99 mil dosis de la
vacuna moderna donada por qatar estas
vacunas ya empezaron a ser aplicadas a
mujeres embarazadas mayores de 18 años y
con más de 20 semanas de gestación son
cerca de 9.000 las mujeres que ya se
registraron para acceder a estas vacunas
en total el país de vacuno a cerca del 6
por ciento de su población total de 7
millones de habitantes estos son estas
son 400.000 personas un poco más de
400.000 personas en total en este
contexto el domingo 20 de junio se debe
realizar las elecciones internas para
las municipales de octubre el ministerio
de salud solicitó la suspensión o
postergación de estos comicios sin
embargo esto no tuvo un visto bueno por
los partidos ni por el tribunal superior
de justicia electoral entonces se
realizarán las elecciones el domingo 20
de junio distintos expertos ya están
anunciando que está hacer esto serán los
comicios con menor participación de la
ciudadanía en toda la historia
democrática
fernando pues completo este reporte
desde la ciudad de asunción muy claro el
panorama allí en paraguay vamos a hablar
ahora de cifras vamos a ver con respecto
al acumulado de casos confirmados de
kobe 19 según el conteo de la
universidad johns hopkins en varios
países de nuestro continente a ver qué
tal cerraron en la semana vamos a hacer
un recorrido primero por países de la
zona andina colombia que es tal vez uno
de los casos más críticos de la región
cierra la semana con 3.6 millones de
casos confirmados y más de 94 mil
personas fallecidas este país sigue
también registrando récords de contagios
y de fallecidos diarios
'ecuador contabilizan más de 436 mil
casos y más de 20 mil 900 personas ya
han fallecido pero cierra esta semana
con 1.9 millones de casos ya se aproxima
rápidamente a la barrera de los 2
millones de casos allí los fallecidos
superan los 187 mil panamá ya fuera de
la región de suramérica los casos
superan los 385 mil allí las víctimas
mortales superan los seis mil
cuatrocientos y nos vamos hasta el
caribe
dominicana registra más de 306 mil casos
confirmados y los fallecidos ya se
cuentan por 3700
y las cifras en uruguay siguen siendo
preocupantes para las autoridades las
cifras de contagio allí son altas pero
al contrario de muchos países la
vacunación está avanzando rápidamente
esta semana la república oriental de
uruguay se convirtió en la primera de
américa latina' en vacunar a los
adolescentes de entre 12 y los 17 años
vamos entonces a montevideo y esta
karina de almas para conocer más
detalles karina como siempre un gusto
tenerla en el programa y comencemos
precisamente por la vacunación de los
adolescentes que ya lo decíamos uruguay
comenzó y unos 157.000 adolescentes se
inscribieron a través de las plataformas
habilitadas por el gobierno para recibir
su primera dosis de vacunación la
población cercana adolescentes de este
rango de edad es de cerca de 280.000
así es uruguay se convirtió en el primer
país iniciar la vacunación adolescentes
entre 12 y 17 años de edad estos
recibirán dos dosis de la vacuna de
facer y el calendario será adelantado
para que puedan reiniciar las clases de
educación intermedia en forma presencial
290 mil adolescentes son los que están
comprendidos para vacunarse se han
agendado unos 160.000 primero recibirán
la vacuna los de 17 años y luego se irá
aplicando la misma bajando en edades los
pediatras aconsejaron este tipo de
vacuna la del laboratorio facer para
este grupo etario señalaron que es
efectiva eficaz que los efectos
secundarios son menores o también
temporales
karina eso en cuanto a los adolescentes
hay un uruguay pero que hay de la
vacunación en general de otras franjas
de edades de otros rangos de edades allí
y que hay también de otras regiones de
los diferentes departamentos no toda la
concentración de la capital de
montevideo que estrategias entonces va a
mantener allí el gobierno uruguayo para
seguir avanzando en esa rápida
vacunación sobre todo en las zonas
rurales
aunque el gobierno uruguayo recibió
muchas críticas al inicio de la
vacunación por ser uno de los países más
tarde en comenzar la en estos momentos
se está desarrollando de forma muy
activa en todo el país la mayoría de las
dosis han sido de la vacuna si novak un
tercio de facer y más de 42 mil de dosis
de astrazéneca en estos momentos la
población que más ha recibido la
vacunación ha sido las personas entre 50
y 70 años de edad el 70% de ellos ya ha
recibido la segunda dosis sin embargo el
14% de la población de 71 a 80 años ha
recibido la vacuna y es que este grupo
etario está recibiendo la del
laboratorio facer que ingresó al país en
forma más tardía el 80% del personal de
esa lucha ha sido vacunado el 70% de los
que trabajan
la educación actualmente más del 55% de
la población ha recibido la segunda
dosis con todos los agendados se
llegaría a un 65 por ciento de la
población con lo cual nos estaría
alcanzando el 70% que dicen los expertos
se necesita para llegar a la inmunidad
de rebaño es por eso que el gobierno
implementó una vacunación pueblo a
pueblo allí las personas se pueden
acercar a los vacunatorios sin agenda
previa y recibir la vacuna la intención
es justamente tratar de llegar hasta
inmunidad de rebaño en estos casos se
aplicará alguna pzifer porque puede
acercar a todos los grupos etarios la
verdad karina es que el caso uruguayo ha
sido bastante particular porque allí fue
tal vez el único territorio de
suramérica que no impuso un
confinamiento estricto se llamó al
autocuidado de los ciudadanos que ellos
mismos restringieran en sus labores y
sus actividades fuera de sus casas y
también se restringió pues eso sí las
clases
precisamente ese es el tema que está
ahora también allí en debate y es el
regreso a las clases presenciales porque
recordemos que este país está por salir
a las vacaciones de invierno que son
vacaciones cortas también está llegando
el clima más frío temperaturas mucho más
bajas y están empezando a evaluar si
finalmente los estudiantes son enviados
por completa las clases hacerlas de
manera presencial uruguay ha sido un
caso destacado en el manejo de la
pandemia en algunas de las fases
recordemos que estuvo además en medio de
dos países muy complicados argentina y
para sí que han tenido picos muy
complicados y muy difíciles de manejar y
también hizo un cierre de la frontera de
las fronteras en general y eso ha visto
al país prácticamente del resto de
países de la región y pues eso le
permitió proteger un poco más a los
ciudadanos
karina entonces qué hay del tema de el
regreso a clases que dicen allí las
autoridades
en cuanto a la educación presencial
santiago como mencionaba un más temprano
los adolescentes eran los últimos en
reintegrarse pero ya a nivel de primaria
se iniciaron las clases en los centros
educativos primero habían retornado a
las clases en el interior del país
hace unos días volvieron en la capital
del país y el área metropolitana que son
las zonas más afectadas por los
contagios desde estos momentos de
coronavirus las clases se retoman
parcialmente primero con primaria y
luego estarán ingresando la educación
media como mencionábamos luego de que
los adolescentes estén vacunados y éstos
volverán a partir de que terminen las
vacaciones de invierno en uruguay
karina muchas gracias por este completo
reporte desde la ciudad de montevideo
allí en la capital de uruguay y vamos a
ir ahora hasta el caribe durante más de
un año y medio la pandemia de kobe 19
allí haití pareció escapar de cierta
forma a los peores estragos del
coronavirus cifras de contagio de
fallecidos allí eran mucho menores y las
comparamos con otros países del caribe y
también con otros países de américa
latina sobre todo con su vecino de isla
la república dominicana sin embargo
mientras avanzaban allí los planes de
vacunación en diferentes países de la
región haití hace frente a un primer
pico de contagio con una infraestructura
hospitalaria muy deficiente y sin
vacunas no han recibido todavía el
primer lote de vacunas así están las
cosas
haití es uno de los pocos países del
mundo en los que no ha sido aplicada una
sola vacuna contra el hobbit de 19 más
aunque tratamos de seguir las
indicaciones para protegernos en haití
no es fácil la gente está muy cerca
entre sí sí yo llevo mi mascarilla los
demás no lo hacen estamos tratando de
respetar el distanciamiento social el
lavado de manos
usando desinfectante de manos pero a
pesar de todo eso no nos sentimos
protegidos no botellas para la próxima
semana se espera la llegada del primer
lote de 130.000 dosis a través del
programa kóvacs diseñado por la
organización mundial de la salud para
los países menos favorecidos hasta hace
poco el virus no representaba la mayor
preocupación para un país acosado por la
pobreza y los desastres naturales ahora
las autoridades temen por el nuevo brote
y hasta decidieron aplazar un referendo
previsto inicialmente para finales de
junio la llegada de las nuevas variantes
y pocas restricciones hicieron que los
casos y las muertes aumentaran más de
cinco veces en apenas un mes generando
estrés adicional aún ya precario sistema
de salud tú estás construyendo
y todos los sitios públicos y privados
están recibiendo pacientes no hay lugar
para más agua o new rose jebet y capas
pop deben abrirse más sitios para
satisfacer las necesidades de los
pacientes respiratorios a fin de evitar
una catástrofe y soldaditos inspirados
en más de un año de pandemia los casos
reportados oficialmente en el país de 11
millones de habitantes nos llegan a los
20.000 y las muertes a las 500 una
proporción relativamente baja en uno de
los países más pobres de la región si se
compara con sus vecinos sin embargo la
comunidad científica lo atribuye a las
limitadas pruebas y dice que las cifras
de reales podrían ser mucho más altas
era el reporte de daniela blandón
contándonos cómo está la situación el
panorama sanitario allí en haití ahora
vayamos a nuestra sección en redes
veamos otras noticias destacadas de la
semana aquí en kobe 19 la semana en
américa
en esta oportunidad estaremos dándoles
noticias de el salvador vamos a comenzar
entonces en centroamérica este país
donará más vacunas de kobe 19
honduras el presidente salvadoreño nadie
que le informó que su país va a donar
dosis de vacunas para que sean
utilizadas en la inmunización de los
habitantes de las llamadas islas de la
bahía es decir roatán josé santos
guardiola utila y guanaja que son
centros turísticos el mandatario también
indicó que va a estar en conversaciones
con el ministerio de salud de honduras
para determinar así el número de dosis
que pueda el salvador suministrarle a su
vecino honduras
y continuamos con un anuncio hecho por
la ope es la organización panamericana
de la salud y esto titula controlar el
kobe 19 en las américas podría llevar
años si continúa el ritmo lento de
vacunación actual así lo advirtió la
directora de la opc carissa etienne
quien advirtió sobre la lentitud con la
que está avanzando la tasa de vacunación
en américa latina y también en el caribe
esto evidencia las desigualdades en la
cobertura y también en el suministro de
vacunas a nivel regional lo hemos
evidenciado acá precisamente haciéndoles
los informes de cada uno de los países
de la región de américa latina
y hablamos ahora de ecuador allí niños
desde los 3 años podrán recibir la
vacuna contra el jove y 19 desde
septiembre de 2021 así lo informó la
ministra de salud ecuatoriana jimena
garzón quien indicó que desde finales de
agosto de este año van a planear desde
la administración del nuevo gobierno en
ecuador cómo van a administrar las dosis
contra el kobe 19 a los niños añadió que
la farmacéutica china sinovac le indicó
que su fórmula de vacuna contra el kobe
19 puede ser aplicada en esta población
con total libertad y sin ningún riesgo
bueno y para el cierre en la
organización mundial de la salud instó a
los ciudadanos europeos a viajar de
manera respeto responsable durante la
temporada de vacaciones del verano
boreal que está por comenzar allí en el
'viejo continente'
la organización advirtió que el
continente de manera de ninguna manera
está fuera de peligro y que la batalla
contra el kobe 19 continúa algo similar
tenemos que tener en cuenta los
residentes de la región de américa
latina que estamos ya a puertas de
comenzar la apertura económica en
algunos de los países y muchas personas
están también tomándose licencias para
viajar a diferentes puntos vacacionales
y también otras personas están viajando
a estados unidos para recibir alguna
vacuna contra el kobe 19 tenemos que
seguir manteniendo los protocolos y
viajando con seguridad
en six mans more than forjando windows
of cover night in boxing en 6 meses se
han administrado más de 400 millones de
dosis de vacunas de ccoo y 19 en la
región
este verano la vacunación debe
realizarse a un ritmo mucho más rápido
al día de hoy 30% de las personas en la
región han recibido al menos una dosis
de vacunas y el 17 por ciento han sido
totalmente inmunizados y presenté las
complete es decir es obvia que hemos
llegado lejos no hemos avanzado lo
suficiente la cobertura de vacunación
está lejos de ser suficiente para
proteger a la región de un resurgimiento
y la distancia que hay que recorrer
antes de alcanzar al menos el 80% de la
cobertura de la población adulta y sigue
siendo considerable y covers of the eye
del population still consideró que hasta
aquí nuestro resumen en kobe 19 la
semana en américa recuerde que puede ver
estos y otros programas en france24
punto com no sobra decir les sigan
cuidando se la emergencia de la pandemia
de kobe 19 se hagan a bandos en las
manos y usando el tapaboca sigan con
nuestra programación sigan con france24
[Música]